day 17 of the Ukraine war and that
familiar Arc of territory occupied by
Russian forces and I'm joined by uh air
marshal Edward Stringer a former
director of operations at the ministry
of Defense Ed we're hearing uh now
reports from Ukrainian authorities that
uh Mario poll down in the Southeast
there uh the outskirts have been uh
occupied by the Russian forces now why
is that such a significant City for the
Russians
no surprises here the surprises that
they they haven't taken it already uh
Mary apple is the second port or on the
Black Sea it's here in the sea of azov
which the Russians have long wanted to
claim as a Russian Lake if you like
um and mariopol has been a thorn in the
side for a while it's also part of that
land bridge connecting Russia through
the donbass all the way down to Crimea
and it might be an indicator of just how
difficult Russians are finding things
that it's taken this this long to really
try and take a city which they must have
thought they would get much earlier
let's take a look at Northern Ukraine
then because there have been significant
movements around the capital uh Kiev
just talk us through what's been
happening
well we know about what's happened there
to the northwest of Kiev because that
was a 40 mile Convoy that that got
itself stuck last week and then we saw
this other line uh of Advance uh heading
west to Kiev from uh from the second
line of communication a second logistic
train that
um uh that has to be uh maintained but
it's a long supply chain that now is
required to to keep all those horses if
they are trying to surround Kiev yes
absolutely and uh what we see and we'll
we'll look at a minute at the close-up
map is this looks like an attempt to
invest Kiev to put to put a cordon
around it but it's another very long
line of communication we're getting into
the spring it's a muddy area narrow
roads forested Ambush country this is
yet another logistic challenge for the
Russians well as you say let's take a
look at a closer map of uh
etc etc those Gateway towns uh bravery
uh in the the East there that has come
under a lot of pressure from Russian
forces and also those towns up in the
Northwest too clearly coming under a lot
of fire from uh from the Russians yes
and what you see these are the tips if
you like of those two thrusts that we
saw on the on the previous map coming
down from the north coming uh coming in
from the East and so yes what you're now
seeing are are firefights in in boat in
both of those areas but what we assume
this is the start of is an attempt to
encircle Kiev but Kiev is a big city
that encirclement is a 50 mile perimeter
that has a huge number of troops that
you've got to resupply once you've put
them in place if you can and we can see
from the latest satellite imagery
evidence of what is happening on the
ground uh this is moshin which is one of
those towns in the the North West there
it's a residential area
yes we haven't had a chance to pick
through all in in detail but so you
don't have to look too closely to see
here that some of these dwellings have
yeah have have been destroyed this is a
residential area it doesn't look to me
like it's a 45 position and yet Russian
shelling has clearly level bit level
bits of it let's be honest this is
Terrorism on the civilian population and
we have got uh evidence in the next
image of of Russian Artillery being
fired now maxar that took these
satellite images says that those are
being fired to the southeast towards a
residential area
yeah so we can't see exactly what the
artillery pieces are here but let's
assume typically medium-sized piece a
D30 would have a range of about 10 miles
16 kilometers which would take it from
there almost into the center of Kiev
which means all the residential areas uh
from here to the center of Kiev are now
in range of these weapons and for
civilians if we have a look at the next
image you can see the the impact on all
those that Russian Firepower massing on
on the very edge of the city that's a
that's gridlock civilians fleeing the
city yes and yeah this is what happens
when you terrorize the civilian
population and you know back to what
we've been discussing before this seems
to me you know indicative of Plan B you
know the Russians aiming to Circle Kiev
aiming to terrorize the population
aiming to put pressure on zelenski to
force some form of compromise well let's
pull back and look at the whole map of
Ukraine because around the country now
we know there have been reports from the
Ukrainian authorities of three senior
Russian generals have been killed in the
conflict so so far what's the
significance of that
major generals two-star generals are not
supposed to be anywhere near the front
line that they are implies they've gone
to the front line to sort out major
problems and that they're just not
making the progress that they're
expected to and therefore they're
they're being picked off at the Russian
claim that they've lost about 500 people
when you've lost three major generals
just cannot be credible it tells me that
the Russian military plan is not going
according to plan
Air Marshal Edward Stringer thank you
very much so clearly you heard from Ed
there that the Russian forces are being
stretched and perhaps taking risks with
their senior Personnel it's the
situation they're being forced into